either of you perfectionists okay uh-huh
how does that how does I'm like
pragmatic he's more of a perfectionist
yeah it's funny my uh my mom he's here
somewhere she she she likes to tell
stories when I was a kid I and I was
coloring in coloring books I would just
go crazy not making things perfect in a
coloring book and I just and I would
just get really upset and that's pretty
much what my life is now with filmmaking
I just I tend to just really obsess and
you know and I think there's a certain I
think with any filming you have to be
willing to just kind of go with the flow
because you just don't have any bility
to make everything perfect but I think
as much as as we can we try to make
everything is close to our vision as
possible and so I guess that means I get
obsessive compulsive sometimes but
that's not entirely a bad thing though
sometimes it is he kind of has to though
because if the person in charge is not
that way everybody else's work is not as
good if that makes sense like that
everybody's following that lead and
everybody wants to achieve what's in
jamuns mind and if he's not really
passionate and certain about his vision
than everything else suffers so it gets
a little bit tough from time to time
when you get really hung up on something
that maybe is not that important but I
can understand why he does and that's
also I understand that's that's exactly
why he does take things so seriously and
they do turn out well in my opinion it's
just it's it's a ton of love and care
and passion that gets poured into that
it's not just happenstance and how does
your being pragmatic balance it out
because that sounds like a great a great
team and once it's because it was too
perfectionists I think that would be
people fighting over their idea versus
another yeah i mean i think there's
there's such a huge part of this that's
just getting the job done you know and
and i think that that's really where
kiowa shines is just as a
she's just very good about just a wee i
always say us about kya that mmm which
sounds not that glamorous but i think
it's a really really big credit to her
is that she is the most competent person
that i know and and that's a really big
thing just to be competent at everything
and especially as a producer and she
just can can get anything done and get
it done efficiently and which for me is
extremely valuable because it allows me
to just focus on the things that i know
are really really important and then you
know if I know something requires
specific attention then you know I'll
let her know and she knows what those
things are it's not like i have to tell
you but so for me I guess it's hugely
liberating because it allows us we're
not spending a lot of time meticulously
going through things that don't matter
for the most part every now that I got
hung up on something but but it's just
that the work you know generally gets
done and then when the way we really
need to focus on something we do she
says yeah I think that's a good idea and
it works because I have no idea what
goes on inside of his head on a
directing and story and vision level and
I would never attempt to do that job I
never would insert myself in a his shoes
or want to do that or try to do that and
and similarly he doesn't step on my toes
so it's not it's not like we're
converging at this one point where we're
both trying to do each other's jobs some
just works out
you